hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 3 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet
they definitely tone down the negan
cussing but he was on a tear this week
really good origin story forward to
white although technically like way back
in season six it was season 6 episode 6
the first time we saw sherry Dwight in
Tina they referenced that meeting
remember when we met we took your stuff
they had escaped with meds but then
Dwight had a change of heart went back
and [ __ ] you know Sherry's kind of
telling Daryl then it got so much worse
we tried to get away did not go well for
us this is like a whole bunch of comic
book stuff happening here it's all right
out of the comic book so they're bait
they're basically trying to make you
sympathize with Dwight most of all but
both Dwight and sherry but mostly Dwight
because he's kind of a mirror for Daryl
in this episode and they're both have
names that start with D so every time
negan says D is my guy like he's slowly
becoming impressed with Daryl he's
becoming a mirror of Dwight but they
just want you to think about Dwight
being really pissed off about being
under negan's thumb so let's do top 10
WTF at Easter eggs number 10
Dwight masterchef Walking Dead Edition
they have this tarantino level montage
with this really weird soundtrack that's
wildly inappropriate for the situation
that they're in like he's just making
this sandwich like a culinary master
watching two people get in a fight then
rifling through the belongings of one of
those guys kind of implying that one of
them died so okay well his stuff belongs
to us now because he doesn't need
anymore
so you learn a little bit about life
inside their compound number nine master
chef dog food sandwich for Daryl so thus
begins the breaking of Daryl or
attempted breaking up Daryl be he's a
tough guy he's not gonna break right
away so they play that creepy Easy
Street song on a loop to make him go
crazy and it reminds you if he never
watched it lost you know really big TV
show where the people in the bunker had
to listen to that downtown song over and
over again so it reminded me of that
just because you go nuts listening to
any song over and over again but this is
just taking it to a really crazy level
so number eight Dwight finally gives him
a jumpsuit with an A on it reminding you
of train car a from terminus back in
season five so anytime you see the
letter
written on anything is just super creepy
but the white starts to explain the
process to him like fall in line or
you're gonna wind up in the pen being
one of these walkers chained up so
number seven we meet sherry again
haven't seen her in a while we learned a
little bit about the dynamic they start
to tease stuff that they explain later
in the episode but sherry seems like a
pretty nice person tries to talk to
Daryl you can see some of the
awkwardness between them and they don't
say it out loud but it's implied that
sherry has been trying to get pregnant
or maybe trying to not get pregnant with
negan because the test was negative so I
think the doctor has just been giving
her pregnancy tests so maybe that has
something to do with her bargain with
negan like she gives him a child he'll
set her free but we can speculate about
that but it just continually gets more
and more horrifying as you learn more
about what's been going on so number six
Dwight starts to open up to Darrel I
mean he's doing negan's thing trying to
break Darryl he's also trying to appeal
to the rational human being inside
Darrel like look dude you trying to hold
out I thought that I was gonna hold out
too but eventually you Neil it's the
right thing to do like he's trying to
turn Darrel to the Savior's even though
you know part of the bargain that negan
made with the survivors when he declared
a truce was that they would keep Daryl
as insurance but they didn't say how
well they would keep Daryl so you know
number five WTF Darrell tries to escape
Sherry's like dude don't don't do it it
gets way worse but he still tries negan
stops short of bashing his head in with
Lucille but I think he's just trying to
hold up his end of the deal like he
knows he needs the survivor supplies
like he needs to keep the supply chain
running in order to do that he has to
uphold his end of the bargain
like negan could kill Daryl but if he
killed Darrell then the survivors would
turn on him and make his life that much
harder like as a psychopath negan does
have a plan but he does need people to
support that plan so he wants the
survivors to give him what he wants so
that's why Daryl's still alive but they
still beat the [ __ ] out of him so he's
just upholding the bare minimum terms of
the agreement but he gives them that
creepy whoareyou line where everyone's
like we're negan we got a taste for that
last season when they went up against
the Savior's for the first time and
they're like where's Nia
in the random saviors like I'm negan it
just doesn't make any sense now that
makes more sense everyone saying they're
negan is their way of saying they've
drunk the kool-aid like they are fully
on negan side but number four Dwight
goes on a side mission to bring someone
back to the flock and you get this
mirror story line with sherry talking to
Daryl about how they tried to escape and
however bad you thought it could be it's
much worse
negan has much much worse waiting around
the corner and then Dwight also kind of
tries to have the same conversation with
this other dude who's trying to walk
away just like Dwight did and eventually
does what the person asks and shoots him
rather than make him go back in that
dovetails nicely with number three the
conversation that Sheree and Dwight have
where they basically say the opposite of
what they really mean at least all this
[ __ ] we're putting up with is better
than being dead which is totally not
true it's totally better to be dead than
be under negan's thumb that's why he
shot that dude because he accepted that
so when he's talking to Sheree and says
that he doesn't really mean it and when
Sheree says that negan is treating her
nicely she's also probably lying so both
Dwight and Sheree are kind of
acknowledging that this is almost worse
than death but they're kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place so
something's going to have to happen some
big thing to shake them out of their
funk like you can see that Dwight is
slowly coming to the conclusion that
this is not better than being dead but
it's gonna take something big to get him
to go against negan so number two this
is really messed up Dwight gives Daryl a
Polaroid of Glenn's mashed head so one
this is really messed up but two it's
kind of a callback for a like a really
offhanded moment when the survivors went
to raid the Savior's compound and there
was a wall with a bunch of Polaroids
with people with mashed heads if you
remember that those were all negan's
victims lucile victims that they had
turned into a Polaroid collage just
completely messed up but my number one
WTF you know very clearly the origin
story of the face iron and how Sheree
became one of negan's wives he's
actually done that with a number of
women in the comics but they might just
window that down a little bit for the TV
show he might only have a
couple wives in the TV show but that all
is basically right out of the comics the
big change they made is that Darryl is
not in the comics so they're really only
been like two big characters that were
ever captured by the Savior's in the
comics that have similar arcs to what's
happening with Darryl there was Carl who
snuck into the Savior's compound so that
he could kill negan and then it kind of
goes in a different direction and then
later in the comics Eugene also got
captured by the Savior's so I guess you
could say this is kind of like what
happened with Carl it's it's a little
bit different because negan really takes
a shine to Carl and wants to take him
under his wing he doesn't really think
of him as his kid but he definitely
tries to turn Carl bring out some of the
darkness inside of him so it's really
interesting arc for him but they've
changed that for the TV show he's trying
to do the same thing with Daryl now but
we'll see how far that gets before she
goes crazy at the Savior's compound let
me know though what was your favorite
moment from the episode was it the
origin story of face iron Dwight and
Cherie or was it just the creepy Daryl
montage of them trying to break him like
an episode of lost the crazy thing about
Dwight I was asking people on Twitter
like during the episode like you know
they're really trying to make you
sympathize with Dwight and Cherie but a
bunch of you guys were like hell no he
is way too bad but do you think that by
the end of this season they will have
done this really crazy Dwight arc where
you do sympathize with him because he
has done some really bad [ __ ] so it's
really hard to forgive him for all that
stuff but it sounds like things are
gonna get even worse for him so they
really really want you to think that
he's not an evil person compared to
negan like he has that crazy [ __ ] bar
line where he's like hey you want some
free tail and Dwight's just like no
thanks when he says blast from the past
that happened before they explained the
Cherie stuff but it's kind of heavily
implied that Dwight is not allowed to
have sex with Cherie anymore even though
he's still in love with her but it's
totally messed up in the best possible
way I love the way they did that opening
montage - that was so good it just shows
you how crazy it is but as some of the
Savior's totally think that it's normal
like Dwight looks like he's slowly
coming to his senses but some of the
others look like they're totally eating
it up
but they wanted to show you in this
episode that not everybody
that's living there with negan is just
like negan so I will say a new round of
the walking dead giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'll do a trailer video
tomorrow I'm also posting Doctor Strange
Easter eggs let me know if there are any
comic book bonus videos that you guys
want me to do later this week too just
because now we are doing a lot of comic
book Niek and stuff they get high I felt
like this episode was a lot better than
last week's episode just really picked
up the crazy slack every once in a while
you do need an episode where they take
their foot off the gas and you just
chill for a little bit but I just love
it when I get super super crazy and
that's what negan is all about this year
well you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for all my
Walking Dead videos and you can click
here to learn how dr. Doo is the new
Iron Man in the Marvel Universe so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight